some of Hollywood's biggest stars are
celebrating a landmark decision by the
Supreme Court on Monday the Supreme
Court ruled that it is illegal for an
employer to fire someone because of
their sexual orientation or gender
identity the six to three ruling adds
LGBTQ people to title seven of the Civil
Rights Act which already protected
against discrimination based on sex race
color national origin and religion
justice Neel Gorsuch wrote an employer
who fires an individual merely for being
gay or transgender defies the law many
celebs were quick to celebrate the news
on social media I'm Ellen and I'm gay
Ellen DeGeneres tweeted about the
historic moment
Kerry Washington shared a bunch of
colorful heart emojis and my big LGBT
advocate anytime I can show my support
it's you know I will and I'll show up
it's awesome Meghan McCain wrote that
the ruling was huge and long overdue and
it's really great to see Cynthia Nixon
said it was a huge victory for LGBTQ
rights and Mandy Moore wrote that the
news is a bright spot in a dark time
it's exciting Busy Philipps Jonathan Ben
s George Takei Clay Aiken Hillary
Clinton Anthony Rapp and Candis Cayne
also shared their excitement and in a
series of tweets Justin Makita wrote
about the landmark win for LGBTQ
equality adding quote I love the idea
that someday all will be treated with
equal dignity and respect tennis legend
Billie Jean King tweeted that Monday's
decision was a huge win for the LGBTQ
community the Supreme Court ruled that
living authentically is not a fireable
offense Janet mock tweeted that the
ruling is a victory hard-won in the
courts and on the streets
I'm deeply hopeful by the work that
everyday people are taking to challenge
conversations at their own dinner tables
et caught up with Janet last week and
she addressed the transgender community
explaining that the fight for equality
starts with your inner circle
exactly where you are at your kitchen
table with your family your community
your chosen loved ones that you know you
have those conversations there and then
there you build more and more and more
to be an activist or to be a
co-conspirator and an accomplice almost
yeah yes an accomplice exactly right you
know we have to be active we have to
mean distant and we have to do the
uncomfortable work of checking and
challenging conversations glad president
and CEO Sarah Kate Ellis also responded
to the ruling telling ET in a statement
quote the Supreme Court's historic
decision affirms what shouldn't have
even been a debate LGBTQ Americans
should be able to work without fear of
losing jobs because of who they are the
decision gives us hope that as a country
we can unite for the common good and
continue the fight for LGBTQ acceptance
[Music]